The international community has been
terribly good at coming up with bryce
ideas.
I'm clever solutions to the problems.
Besetting nations like Pakistan,
they have been woefully poor at
implementing those ideas.
Center of Islamic radicalism,
the hiding place of his.
I'm a bit and the only us ally,
which Washington regularly bombs.
At least the drones do not kill British
and US servicemen.
We will never leave Pakistan because
Pakistan is part of Britain,
India and Pakistan and I'm glad they are
bone or the same room,
but it was more than that,
but it was just a Zambian section.
Einstein defined madness is doing the
same thing over and over again and
expecting a different result.
This is madness.
Of course.
I'm representative.
I mean what makes me unrepresentative
just because I speak English this
evening.
I'll have a conversation with you if you
want later on.
That makes me more sensitive.